way to do in this quarantine and June of
course is Pride Month and to celebrate
we're joined by two filmmakers who at
the forefront of the new queer cinema
movement very thrilled to happen both
with us I'll do matrix quickly seeing as
their times getting on first up he's the
righty director of queer classics such
as mala noche and my own Private Idaho
the indie classic Drugstore Cowboy he's
twice Oscar nominated for Best Director
for Good Will Hunting and milk he's five
times Spirit Award nominee for Best
Director and a two-time winner for Best
Screenplay he's one of the few
filmmakers to win Best Director and the
Palme d'Or
for the same film can I was elephant his
other films include last days paranoid
Park and most recently don't worry he
won't get far on foot the great Gus Van
Sant is with us welcome Gus thank you
thanks with us you are here at the
request of our other guest he's the
writer director actor behind the now
classic genre-bending and gender-bending
stage and screen musical Hedwig and the
Angry Inch for which he was nominated
for three Spirit Awards these other
credits include short bus rabbit hole
and how to talk to girls at parties he's
acting credits include girls vinyl and
most recently shrill that's on Hulu
great John Cameron Mitchell is with us I
don't hi
I think we've used up all our time with
our guest well that was great to see you
both how's the quarantine holding up Gus
and I were in a quarantine pod for a
while in in Palm Springs which is where
the traditionally where the gays go to
die
but we came that we went there to live
do they yeah until they die
but it was a great place to to hide and
it's gorgeous and now I'm in Point Reyes
in the Bay Area and heading to
Provincetown going to all the gate gate
spots yes you in Oregon I'm in Palm
Springs oh no so that's how we met year
John was you were seeking refuge right
from you were just learning Eleanor yeah
you couldn't guess that I was on tour
with my head big theme concert tour the
origin of love crab surfing and and
spreading kovat unwittingly no I wasn't
but then I decided New York probably
wasn't the best place to be right a lot
of parties or people's attention during
the quarantines of yes in New York
parties yes the meth the meth ball so
how this works the coffee talks are
moderated conversation so I'm gonna sort
of step off this virtual stage and let
you both chat for about half an hour and
catch up talk shop and then I'll be back
with some questions from the audience
the audience can use the Q&A button at
the bottom of the screen and we'll try
and get through as many of those as
possible but for the aren't so over to
the two of you thanks well Gus it was
we've been talking a lot this summer but
you know there's a different one of the
things that we're all dealing with you
know even before covered was the
understanding that the kind of things
that we make you know smaller films have
gone a bit out of fashion yeah because
of the internet and because of the way
people see things now and you know even
our friends not going to the movie
theater as much of course they're not
going at all do you think this pandemic
is actually going to shift that even
more to this smaller screen and make it
more difficult to finance obviously it
shifts it to the smaller screen but then
the smaller screen you have a lot of in
the
and works that are you know on YouTube
or all over the place and you know valid
amazing works so I think it's kind of
good in some ways for smaller filmmakers
and you know political filmmakers or
[Music]
many other kind of filmmakers yeah do
you think the streamers are gonna still
finance or expand financing on the
smaller less starry films have you found
that to be the case lately well I think
that there's yeah there's a lot of need
for materials so I think it will
naturally sort of bleed over into the
into everyone that's that's making
things so I see that happening I'm
really I don't have a personal like you
know project
yeah with a streaming company but
someday I thought you do don't you with
the talking yeah actually I'm talking
with one company about this small
project but you know it's in development
yeah yeah and I'm working on a couple of
TV projects to I mean have all this both
of us obviously stories are stories and
some can be told you know over a longer
period of time and the things were used
to making tend to be in in time is
really more like short stories films are
really short stories and series are more
novels or at best and you know we can
have a taste for both of them and in
fact it's kind of shocking to me when
people tell such a full story in an hour
and a half I mean it after watching so
much TV now you're like how the hell do
people do that how did we do that it's
hard it's hard I mean although that's
what we do so it seems hard to make
something that is endless you know that
is like in ours especially when I watch
a streaming show at some it kind of goes
by in a strange way like a different way
than in a theatre yeah
it's like reading partly and then it's
like you kind of spaced out yes
and a lot of them are very plot driven
so the more moodier features that we
that we like we wouldn't really
translate to a long a long story
necessarily because there's something
also about the home viewing experience
where people are doing other things
while watching which I find annoying but
it's what happens you know people pee
they check their phone their check their
email they even take a call during it
and of course the way people create
their TV shows are almost taking that
into account like repeating information
which I always find annoying you just
said that you know but then there's a
lot of great shows I mean I've been
watching I've been enjoying the great
you know which is the Catherine the
Great series done by the people who made
the favorite and what we do in the
shadows is so much fun I don't know if
you've cut that one the vampire one I
don't have any moment it's fun it's the
guy you know it's the flight of the
conchords and Taika Waititi created
alone very fun it's like laying vampires
in Staten Island and and then started
watching I may destroy you I don't know
you know it's this woman Mikayla Cole
who's did a series in Britain called
chewing gum which is really funny and
this is a more realistic she's dealing
with a possible sexual assault that she
doesn't remember you know and it's
really well made I just got through the
first two so there's there's tons of
good stuff in the lockdown we've both
kind of been guiltily enjoying the
productivity of the lockdown yeah yeah
trying to I mean at least there's you
know something for me to work on and you
- you're working on something yeah and
then ever
writing songs yeah how how was the
Lindsey Graham song if you guys go on
social media or YouTube look up B
Lindsey Graham it's a song that Lance
horn wrote and I sang on which is using
the the lyrics are the tweets that have
been coming out from sex workers saying
that they've been male sex workers
they'd been with Lindsey Graham and it's
time to to out him and put a stop to
this Trump you know Trump puppet who
probably got blackmailed in order you
know because he used to be the big Trump
questioner and was the best friend of
McCain you know the only senator
standing up to trump and who is of
course humiliated in life and death by
Trump so Lindsey house is gonna be
spending time in his personal circle of
hell
that he's created so we made a song
called B Lindsey Graham using the text
of the tweets and it's a lot of fun if
you check it out and is it a story
that's like been confirmed or is it
still well I mean confirmed as much as
anything in that two or three sex
workers have come out saying that you
know that he hired them so it's you know
kind of their word I don't think he's
really responding right now yeah I mean
I don't think it's really hit the
mainstream like I've only seen you know
in gay press and in social media there's
been a couple of you know local sent
South Carolina mentions of it and their
it pains to say there's nothing wrong
with the fact that he would be gay you
know we're reporting this and it's I
think they're taking that moral high
road of like how dare they out someone
who's been voting for homophobic
legislation
I don't believe in Audi unless someone
is truly dangerous like him you know
there was a few Congress people that
were outed who were clearly anti-gay and
good riddance you know it's like and how
did you get to be part of that project
with Lance was writing it or yeah Lance
is ready he's a wonderful cabaret legend
in San Francisco in New York and he we
did we did songs we've done songs
together before so he just said would
you do you know a bit of this and it's
been great and I'm I'm starting to write
you know songs with all kinds of people
even strangers on the internet which has
been a lot of fun and like for instance
that song did you uh did you record it
at home or did you go into it yeah yeah
because I because I've been making
podcast series that was another form
that we can talk about is you know as
film becomes a bit more difficult
television fictional podcasts of course
web series which seem to be losing their
luster lately and pure music you know
are other venues for storytelling and I
made a series called anthem homunculus
which is on the luminary platform but in
that I learned how to really you know
get a nice mic and a preamp and so I
carry that with me and that's how I've
been writing songs with so many people's
I have my own stuff I can just record
off my computer and it feels very
freeing and then you know one song I
wrote with a stranger in France we did a
duet I got my friend Cassie to do harp
in New Orleans Lance did strings with
thorgy thor who was a member of drag
race and then a guy kevin radarman mixed
it in LA and everyone does it for free
and for fun and hopefully we'll make a
kovat benefit
or black lives matter or you know
whoever's in need at that moment with
the stuff that we've been making great
that's awesome yeah and are you working
on a new podcast um you're finished with
anthem finished with anthem that's out
which kind of sprang from a Hedvig
sequel but became more about my life if
I had never left my small town and
because for podcasts and short things
it's very easy to get very great people
because you can do it very quickly and
so we have Glenn Close and Laurie
Anderson Cynthia areevo and you know
Patti LuPone we have an amazing cast
because I can do their whole season in
two or three days and write for their
voices you know for their singing and
speaking voices so it's a wonderful form
and I may do that with one of my stories
that I have been trouble having trouble
getting on television which is really
feels very about today you know it's
like if we could start over as a nation
how would we do that you know what what
would our Constitution be like now one
that you know in effect our Constitution
is the oldest working Constitution in
the world even though it's only two
hundred and seven years old and it shows
there's some cracks in it and that's
what the amendments were supposed to fix
but of course in this polarized time no
one's gonna be adding any amendments you
know that's why the Supreme Court is so
important and this election is so
important in many ways so many ways it's
amazing how many ways it's lately and
it's very exciting to see the changes on
you know to see what's going on in the
street and in terms of black metal which
never would have happened without you
know covered without kovat without Trump
stumbling on kovat and without those
horrible events that happened right back
to about
yeah um yeah the fact that people can go
can go every day and and March and
protest it's not miss work or school
yeah it's amazing amazing timing yeah
and and really I think the coded staying
inside really fueled like a lot of
energy that burst out onto the street
yes and the weather helped and you know
and the cops didn't help of course I
have friends who are cops and they're
very ashamed
they're very ashamed of you know the
whatever percentage of them that are
power have problems with power and and
tend to abuse it yeah you don't you
don't get firemen brutality you know
doesn't attract that but you also
attracts good people so you know I I see
change happening and perhaps being the
thin end of the wedge for other change
that's necessary for health care for
education for economic equality and you
know at this election will be is more
historic than ever
yeah for sure and what happens between
now and the election
question scary oh yeah
yeah he's undies not above any any
tactic now you know starting a war
whatever it is I wrote something on
Instagram where I predict I had a
prediction of January 1st when the you
know when the new hopeful president
comes in which I'm thinking of making
into a song which does involve
cannibalism yeah but it's funny you were
mentioning us being part of the new
queer cinema we're definitely the old
person actually no even I I think that
you were part of them the new queer
cinema at the time I think I was a
little bit I was older than everybody
else I feel like you and Derek Jarman
were
the godfathers yeah we were he was even
earlier but you know we were yeah
earlier a bit but it was an amazing turn
of events and an amazing moment in time
and I feel like Sundance was like one of
the helpers you know for people to see a
lot of queer cinema and gay cinema
Sundance and the Sundance labs run by
Michelle Saturday unspoken st.
independent American film from the
beginning their mission was to get
voices out that were not being heard and
in the labs which I went to was
indispensable for me there were there
were voices from all parts of America
and that was very much part of their
deal before many other people were
thinking in terms of diversity and you
know my classmates went on to produce
you know Empire and make you know
Winter's Bone and and you know these
were amazing people I wasn't even a
filmmaker and I I learned so much from
that four-week experience and I Michele
is really very humble but she has done
more than anyone in the last 25 years to
to make film make the best of what
American film is yeah you know and you
you were even my advisor at the lab I
wasn't it yes I was sort of happened to
be there for another reason and then I
joined the advisory group which I
remember Alfonso Cuaron was one of them
and Delroy and window yes
forgetting others but it was a his
amazing period and and you like you had
developed Hedwig as a stage act at Don
Hills yeah or Squeezebox was it was
their life before Don Hills Squeezebox
is where I did my very first gigs for
had big which was a punk-rock drag Club
in 94 it started and I was a more
traditional actor you know Broadway and
TV and I but I felt punk rock and drag
were more exciting then stuff I was
seeing on Broadway for sure and I
thought its what is more Broadway than
drag or punk you know they are very
theatrical and it was only homophobia
and middle class you know panic that
made them not that stop them from being
on stages you know that worse it was
Charles bull erst it was Charles Ludlum
who were certain working drag onstage
but you know the intensity of Squeezebox
and singing these by you know violently
rebellious songs coming from Queens that
didn't even know they were punk they
were lip-synching when they realized
with punk they could use their own voice
and be even more effective instead of
imitating or commenting on chair or
Diana Ross and it was so thrilling to
watch them and learn from them you know
Lady Bunny and Jean County and Mistress
Formica and all of these people badge
vaginal cream Davis who was six foot
five is a six and five you know she
would not call herself a drag queen but
she's definitely a you know has worked
with gender and rock'n'roll and music
and she had a band called black [ __ ]
woods I loved so these were my mother's
my drag mothers and so when I got to
slow down so you started out with just
just songs or was there the monologue as
well there was a story a vague story
using the origin of love you know the
idea of seeking your other half but
Tommy gnosis used to be the lead and he
was the son of the general who became a
rock star and head big was based on my
babysitter who was also a prostitute
from Germany a biological woman and
being in the club full of
Bagon trans and and rock-and-roll it
influenced the story and hedvig became
the main character much more interesting
than but the what Hedwig won out
Hedwig won even though she's had a hard
life but she's made original you came
out as Tommy gnosis and then he would
show up
well Tommy was just part of the script I
actually did one Tommy show because at
one time if people know the play it's a
single gig next door to a stadium where
her lover time he knows this is
performing having me stolen her songs
right so I thought it'd be interesting
to do ahead big show and then a Tommy
show on the stadium like two shows
alternating and I had a whole story for
Tommy about him being replaced by a
stalker who took you know did plastic
surgery to take over his career while
the real Tommy is is tied up somewhere
you know with a video camera in front of
his face so I did one gig as Tommy which
was so bad that I I I was talking to
some homeless people on the street while
dressed up in silver makeup getting
ready to go on I said come on in to the
club and watch my show so they thought I
was a real rock star telling the story
of you know being drunk and killing a
lot of disabled kids which ended my
career and this was my comeback and I
had this whole thing where I was gonna
stage dive and not be caught so I had
like stage blood and like Chiclets in my
mouth to spit out teeth so I did a stage
dive where nobody was and I hit the
floor and was like you know bleeding and
teeth spit out and the homeless people
were like but it was it never took off
Tommy wasn't sloppy yeah well you know
I'm trying to also reminding people that
on the quite
and channel both of the films you
mentioned my own private auto Idaho and
mala noche are playing yeah as well as a
film that we helped along called
tarnation carnation just got put on
that's great yeah it's a brilliant film
by Jonathan couette which is I think of
as like an autobiography I had yeah such
an amazing film really useful the Elmer
and but it's told in the most
intoxicating way and he really did make
most of it on his you know pre 2004
movie program the iMovie program which
really he used to the extent to the hilt
to the hilt yeah yeah it's a beautiful
film if anyone hasn't seen it check out
tarnation it's a queer classic and also
it I remember it was also fun I said I
have fun in the marketing of films or
other people's films
it's a different it's a different skill
to making a film and many filmmakers
hate it right they're just like oh well
I actually enjoyed the challenge of it
and I remember when we were marketing it
at Sundance you know Steven winter the
producer and I were thinking about it
and I said to Jonathan how much did this
before music rights and film rights how
much did this film really cost to make
because a lot of it is his home movies
that he shot when he was a Hertz yeah
yeah just homemade eighties tapes of
himself and his mother and he said well
it's it was about $200 if you just count
the tapes and I said oh no it was two
hundred and eighteen dollars and 32
cents
you can't say $200 to the press because
they won't believe it so I give them an
exact amount and that was the the
headline for the first feature in the
time so it was like when you came to
Portland you're working on
and you're writing and you had a goodbye
party you were going back to New York
and people would come in and they would
sort of rush up to me and say have you
seen tarnation and I didn't know what it
was because you had showed it to
different people during your stay in
Portland
yes Portland and I kept hearing about it
just because it was like the greatest
movie they'd ever seen I think it was
maybe Greg sacks or Jimmy Bolton and yet
Dan getting Dan's last thing but um yeah
and they showed it to you a tape no you
asked for a tape because they kept
people kept telling me about it and I
said do you have anything and I think
you had you had like something to show
it was three hours long yeah it was the
first cut yeah which was very
mesmerizing
yes very mesmerizing and Sundance it
wasn't particularly didn't didn't get a
lot of love on the Village Voice was the
only one who really said it was the most
interesting film of the festival but
then it it took us getting to the
Directors Fortnight in can to get it
into the world and but at the time you
had to have a print for a can and a
print could cost $25,000 and which
seemed very unfair to these young
filmmakers that they would demand a
print when there was still pretty good
when it was a ton of dollars yeah there
was pretty good HD cams that could play
but you know it was France and you know
very traditional so we were running
around I was doing benefits to try to
get the money and we finally found a
distributor the wonderful wellspring to
Maiden look but that was the thing Steve
ban and ran it was he at can Steve never
met him I don't think he was but
Jonathan Mann and it was like years
later when Trump was in we were like oh
my god tarnation and a brown bunny
we're sponsored by the guy who wants to
you know
get you know all the non-white people
out it was just very embarrassing
he also if you recently there's a
documentary about biosphere oh yeah he
spirit well it was taken away from the
original guy and he was he was brought
in to be the new face biosphere and he
looks like an [ __ ] back then too I
mean he was just thinner
I wish they'd left him in the biosphere
but Malin notes he was a big deal for me
Gus cuz you know I was coming up in the
80s not even though I came out of
traditional theater and even Broadway I
wasn't of it and I was looking for those
you know the alt queer filmmakers the
the ones that I thought of was the more
you know Punk and you know the original
punk filmmaker queer filmmakers were
probably you know who like Jean Jane a
really with unshelled um wore his
brilliant short Cocteau who was less
Punk but he was definitely you know a
queer icon I mean there were a lot of
great directors also in Germany who were
who were very out in their own in their
own special way but it took it took
really you and Derek Jarman Fassbender
you know yeah the spender was really you
know the unapologetic you know queer
master even though he had very little
hope the world was very fierce yeah he
was fierce as hell and you know of
course I'm a devar and the early 80s was
important and in certain films like
parting glances and you know always
resonated
but for some reason mala noche really
hit me the hardest and I remember I
wrote you up
and letter I don't know if you got a lot
of fan letters back then I think you and
Gregg Araki Oh
that I remember yeah and then you found
a picture of me when I auditioned for
drugstore cow yeah exactly a Polaroid
where my you know I still use it as my
headshot but I think we can use some
time to for people to ask questions
don't you then yeah for sure there's no
one there unmute my phone here it's
before we get the questions I actually
did we watched some of your movies gasps
I rewatched
my own Private Idaho last night in
preparation with this I'd seen if since
since it came out
Wow amazed how much stuck with me and
then I remembered but one thing I'd
completely forgotten is that one of the
John's is Mickey Cottrell yeah your old
co-conspirator where the party's at
Sundance that's right that's right used
to have the best parties
he had the queer parties there in the
early 80s at this former church and he
would joke he was like that was the time
where they found that the size of your
hypothalamus could determine if you were
queer and he was he was measuring
hypothalamic the door and I I remember
it was too much for the party was too
queer for some I think John Cusack ran
screaming but Brad Pitt always a friend
of the gays
I think sat on the fence outside in the
Sub Zero and I was like Brad come on and
he was like I'm good on the fence he was
always a good guy but yes I met so many
people there who I worked with later
Christine vashaun Todd Haynes
Christopher moon
Tom Kalin who helped me at Sundance and
I was just a little punk with know
nothing about a picture and resume which
I handed to Christine's your mind
I'm handing a picture and resume to
someone at a film festival so uncool and
Mickey was the person I'm thinking
somewhere like me we may have been after
Sundance where he said to me you have to
see that I wanted to see this movie that
the festival was over but he sent me to
a screening of tarnation's he was the
one that was was doing the publicity for
it and told me to go and see it blew my
mind he was in my film Shortbus as well
as Gus's film Private Idaho in Shortbus
he's a body that at the bottom of a
jacuzzi that someone steps on he was
very up for it and then he was the
hilarious clean freak in in Idaho and
one of the fun things being in Palm
Springs during covetous Gus introduced
me to you dope here another queer icon
of film who's done 250 films yeah and
was a boyhood friend of phosp in der in
cologne when they were both boy hustlers
at the gay bar
so there's showed his movie yeah we
should baccara which was amazing which
is so great and he was the villain
soldier of fortune but you got to get
you got an interview dough for film
Internet yeah so some questions here
first one up from jet asks you both how
do you feel queer cinema has shifted or
changed since you both started out well
it's just proliferated for the fridge to
the point where it's a sickness on my
YouTube feed it's like everywhere all
the shorts features it's just I mean
it's amazing yeah a chant it's a big
difference sometimes you know one of the
prices of acceptance is is a little bit
of you know a nothing mediocrity but
like maybe less wrists
you know people were panicked that gay
marriage would just make us all into you
know straight sheep I actually disagreed
and I think it's actually helped
marriage as an institution made straight
people consider their own laziness and
gender roles and monogamy and things
like that but I am sort of missing the
quote unquote punk queer films that
really launched me and you know as
things get more accepting there's you
know RuPaul has kind of standardized
drag it's definitely given a lot of
careers to a lot of talented people but
it feels a little bit standardized you
know you have to lip sync you have to do
this and that and to me drag was a form
that you can do a lot of things with
just like film um I feel like other
countries have been a little bit more
interesting lately with their queer
films because they're still in major
minority and certainly trans people who
have faced more problem more resistance
lately than just gay people have been
pushing the limit you know pushing it
storytelling in a more interesting way
but I don't know we both came up in the
Warhol the Fassbender the you know the
the german era and those iconoclasts i
want more you know i want to see who the
other freaks are not just queer because
queer is a neutral thing that you can do
something you can do something radical
with you could do something simple and
and you know useful like loves Timon or
any number of of let's say mainstream
things which are important to baccarat
is that how you say it background is one
of you one of those finds yeah I mean it
was it comes from a queer lens you can
see that was not overtly queer you know
the gangster
icon in that was played by a person who
usually does drag but you don't really
you don't really get it you know it's
more it's just more fabric of the which
is ultimately perhaps our goal is to
just remind ourselves that the fabric is
broad and you know diversity of story
not just diversity of identity the goal
is that everything is game for stories
everything and every form you know with
Shortbus I just was looking at Catrin
Brea and other people and John Jay and
Frank rip Lowe who made taxi to Clos
which was very influential queer film
that used real sex and I said well these
people are using sex in an interesting
thoughtful way and it wasn't that
American thing it's like sex is it has
to be hot or it's not what's the purpose
no that's the sort of capitalist porn
version of sex you know porn is required
porns job is to jerk off to whereas sex
is much more you know it's more complex
to be just left to porn you know there's
so much going on there and it's my our
version was more kind of a comic
melancholy so to me maybe films don't
need to be just about queer people you
know you Gus are a queer person so that
just suffuses anything you make is your
experience so is finding force or a
queer film maybe you know it's about an
outsider trying to fit in um Sean
Connery was playing him as a gay man he
was his character yeah but the studio
didn't really want to hear anything
about that pretty much but he was
playing that young really I mean it was
a chosen family story you know and
that's a queer story which is different
from say an african-american story where
you don't necessarily have to come out
to your parents
as black you know so a queer point of
view is going to be always different
it's maybe in some ways closer to the
though not equated in any way but I just
saw the film crib camp that my buddy
Howard Gertler produced and there I was
like wow this disabled movement feels
very queer to me
because you know I could go to a gay bar
and Turkey and meet someone from
Azerbaijan and you have an instant
kinship of queerness that crosses
borders and races and gender even it
doesn't mean you like everybody but
there's a kind of instant thing that
happens I understand - of like in the so
called clip [ __ ] community of disabled
people where you don't fit in with your
family necessarily then you have to make
your chosen family so the idea of chosen
families of marginalized group telling
stories is going to I mean every artist
has feels has felt left out I think
that's part of the reasons they are they
are artists so you're always going to
get the misfits in the arts and
humanities and queer is just one you
know one way to look at the world as we
move towards some acceptance and you
know we now have you know married with
the two kids in the suburbs and then a
Labrador like what is the new queer
cinema look like in that world do you
think we see a gay James Bond Thanks
that's queering of the mainstream is
that possible Jimmy Jimmy bond did you I
I was working on a queer Jamie bond like
a this is for fun I think just in Vivian
bond I would love that my gosh you know
when people were like black panther
breaking you know breaking boundaries
you know african-american being as
mainstream as
making it as mainstream of film as
Ironman or at any other I'm being a hit
that was important
personally the film didn't really do
much for me you know one of our goals is
to be as you know he is feel like
everybody else
you know make money like the people that
are in charge make and you know to me I
found the message garbled in that I
didn't think it was that's smart but it
was you know well made well acted so I
think a bit of that in the queer realm
would be great you know I'd love to see
you know the queer Nancy Drew I mean she
obviously always was queer in my view
but you know I love to queer the
mainstream but I also think it's very
important to remind ourselves that you
know nurturing the outsiders is that's
where we came from I think where people
will always have a sense of the outside
again because their families are not
necessarily queer but the price of this
assimilation is fewer suicides fewer
queer bashings if the result is more gay
Republicans well you know that's just
that's I'll pay that price you know and
it's sad but you know weirdly I've been
playing you know a version of Milo you
Napoles is the ultimate Quisling you
know kind of opportunist queer and
coulter type who seems to be burning
bridges right left which is sad because
he seems fairly smart but um he but you
just found a nice like a again yeah we
immediately got pulled out from under
him because because he's an [ __ ]
and you're playing him I'm playing a
version of him in the good fight on CBS
called you know but it's really fun
because
actually upgrading his personality that
make more fun but I sang a song called
hi Archie there's the dog I'm living I
there was an episode where Hillary wins
it's a fantasy episode Hillary won the
presidency and I have a show on the
Trump Network and I'm singing this wall
is you're a wall you know and all these
you know kind of Andy Williams type
songs for and make make them for Trump
but hopefully that our satire for Trump
will be over in a few months
a question from via BIA who asks you
both to talk about your rehearsal
process with actors and how it has
evolved over the years especially non
musical sequences do you rehearse a lot
Gus um yeah I mean I I think when I
first started out I had you know small
rehearsal periods but then Drugstore
Cowboy was the one where we had sort of
an ensemble for people and we just
mostly what we would do was read from
the script but then in that case
everyone would go off the page and do
things that they would normal you know
they would do in character in that case
they were robbing drugstores in the
story so we decided to go drive to a
drug store and they were all in
character Kelly Lynch and Matt Dillon
James degrow and Heather Graham were
sort of casing a drug store and I
remember we had a car accident on the
way a little fender bender and they sort
of handled it in character so sort of
loose loosens you up that was a helpful
aspect of it I think it's super useful
in creating bonds between the characters
by way of the actors if you're married
you want to
she want to do stuff together to just
get your shorthand communication and
vibes doing scenes themselves sometimes
because film is so fast you don't I
think both Gus and I are aware of the
dangers of over rehearsing especially
emotional scenes you don't want to you
know cry them out before you get to the
scene and an actor will be aware of that
an actor will sometimes ask for
rehearsal or say no where so please
maybe just talking you know just talking
about the scenes for theater you have
months to get ready so you you know it's
kind of good too but you film you really
get to do that for Shortbus we actually
had no script and I just cast
interesting people who might want to go
down the journey with me of using sex in
a different way and some were
pre-existing couples and some were you
know new fake couples and we were only
rehearse the sex a couple of times and
maybe I thought of it like a crying
scene you don't want to shoot your log
and but it was interesting to do a
sexual scene like any scene the
character needs to know what they want
and that's often the best direction is
not you know I think Gus will agree that
the worst direction is putting a don't
before it you know if someone is moving
their hands too much and say don't move
your hands all they think about is their
hands and they can't act anymore but -
you might say you're incredibly calm
telling this story so do it very you
know give it a minimal do do as little
as possible and go light laser beam and
then instantly the hands go away but
that's a positive way of doing it as
opposed to a negative because the
negative just makes an actor
self-conscious and Gus is great at
giving actors respecting them giving
them their space
which is why he always attracts great
actors I think I do too because we we
respect them as partners rather than
think of them as pawns you know there's
a lot of great filmmakers like Kubrick
but actors were chess pieces you know
what most people reported that what
about the process of working with a
group of actors where they have
different methods and some take a while
to warm up and others don't want a lot
of rehearsal because they're kind of
very fresh straight out take one or two
how do you square that circle yeah I had
a situation where out of the two leads
one lead really refused to go off the
page and the other lead only wanted to
go off the page so then somehow it
worked out so I'm not sure how that
worked out but you just do it and
something would happen and that was I do
I think like for Shortbus I did have
experienced actors and then not
experienced actors and I found the best
way was first of all we created story
through improv and even in their
auditions there were stories they told
that I would say all right I want you to
help create this character exaggerating
elements from your own life so for
example the lead woman had had some
problems accessing her aura good first
orgasm when she was younger and I said
what if you take it to the limit she's
never had one and even farther and she's
a sex therapist and and so we started
with that and did a lot of improv and so
she the actors brought stuff from their
own life and exaggerated it then I wrote
a script and I told them I found that
they were better when they were
paraphrasing the script as opposed to
doing it verbatim verbatim is easier for
experienced actors so I said you can
never learn the script never learn a
verbatim but if the scene has ten
you still have to do 10 lines but
paraphrase them in your own way for each
take and with certain things to help the
editor for example they drink a glass of
water after five lines always do that
and then leave after the ten lines so
the editor is you know not too crazy
trying to do continuity but it really
relaxed them and you could rehearse in
the paraphrasing way which I think
people like Cassavetes would do Altman
had his own version Woody Allen you know
they all worked with versions of improv
closer to the script or farther and
closer to my script was better because
you wouldn't get the ignore you know the
tangents that would drive you a little
bit crazy but you still had spontaneity
so for Shortbus and even for how to talk
to girls at parties and a little bit of
Hedwig I used this paraphrase thing and
that worked for the non-professional
actors as well as the professional they
could work together that way really well
have a try for about two or three more
questions you just Daniels
are there any characters in your film if
you would like to revisit how to revisit
yeah hmm I don't think so I mean
sometimes I mean not know I guess the
answer's no but I always wondered about
Good Will Hunting whether or not Matt
Damon and Ben Affleck would write like a
story at their age now you know like um
but that sort of it depends on whether
they would write it so it about that I
think they would be so fun this time
yeah with Idaho I had got I had wanted
to make that into a television series
on the Fox Channel and I pitched it but
it didn't fly recommendation asking you
for good gay what pump fans
BAM well the downtown boys are great
mostly women of color actually and some
guys I mean there's there's so many
queer musicians now that you don't they
don't even feel the need to come out
anymore you know yeah my my friend's kid
is is teenager gay and she's like is
there something you'd like to tell me
it's like mom nobody does that anymore
it's like uncool because it's like why
should you you know cuz it's just who I
am
but you know obviously nobody wants to
be told by their parents to come but I
think you could do better to just Google
you know that there's always a listicle
of the queer punk bands of the moment
but I feel like women especially in rock
are more ascendant right now you know
it's like it used to be the mail place
right the rock thing even though the
original rocker was a queer black man
called Little Richard the original punk
you know and David Bowie and Little
Richard and John Lennon and Paul
McCartney were all looked to him as The
Godfather even more than Chuck Berry em
or Elvis and the two you know the two
deaths that affected in this copán well
the disco
time were well Richard Larry Kramer and
Hal Hal Willner who was an amazing
musical force yeah he died of kovat and
his his covers album of t-rex was about
to come out and will come out this fall
with amazing people you know u2 and
Elton John and and lesser-known people I
actually get to do a cover of my
favorite t-rex song which is actually
used in velvet goldmine which was a I
never got to work with Todd as an actor
he's even though he tried to cast me in
two of his films because they were so
low-budget I couldn't afford to fly
myself there so I had to do off-broadway
theater because there was more money a
question for you guys from OMA do you
mind talking a little bit about visual
language of elephant and how it involve
evolved whether you had any references
yeah originally I sort of came from this
effort when we did Jerry movie Jerry
which was Casey yeah and Matt Damon and
and there's the story was about these
two guys that are lost in the desert
which was based on a true story and I
thought it was making a John Cassavetes
kind of thing and I was reading a lot of
John Cassavetes books books bought about
him and his methods and I think when we
we started making it it sort of turned
into something different and we started
emulating instead of Cassavetes we were
emulating something I had seen in the
works of bailet our Oh who's a Hungarian
film maker and he had very very long
pensive takes so we started doing that
in that particular film and I felt like
I wanted to do more of that
and it was that particular film was
strange because it didn't start out that
way
it started out with a pretty standard
screenplay and then I tried to bail from
the project it was an HBO project and
they wouldn't they didn't want me to
they they really wanted to go forward
with the project and I I sort of started
making ultimatums like I want it to be
like Jerry I want it to be slow and
pensive and tried to get sort of out of
the project and they kept saying yes and
so finally we found ourselves like you
know casting there and I think Harris
savita's who had also shot Jerry was the
DP and we didn't really know what we
were gonna do until the day of you know
you can always change your mind just
before you start so you kind of like had
these things in the air and finally we
kind of committed to these the style
which was also written in the script by
then I had rewritten the script to be
kind of a poem rather than a traditional
screenplay it was only like 20 pages and
we we sort of kind of did another
another version of something like Jerry
stylistically slow cinema in that thing
right I mean it's ours
yeah and like he he was sort of I think
um John schoo who was like another I'm
guy will make her very famous filmmaker
who made the red and the white and he he
also used very slow pensive takes and
then of course before him like Tarkovsky
mm-hmm was was doing stuff like that but
you know there was a tradition see usual
deal lost days kind of falls under that
- yeah in last days we kept going except
last days was literally Jean Gilman
because we were in a house it was
different and we started actually using
more mechanical architectural like
angles to shoot the action Li always
kind of like at right angles from the
from the room and and John Newman was I
think one of our big inspirations
Aukerman has a lot of effect on queer
filmmakers you know Todd Haynes loved
her and John Gilman is a classic you
know feels like elephant to me you know
it's a classic tale of like somehow real
real time becomes tense you know and
when things kick in they're extrude
because of the pace they're very
powerfully jolting when the you know
certain events happen and elephants you
know the most beautiful moment is at the
end when the father just puts his arm on
the shoulders of his son looking towards
the school where they're shooting has
happened and it's just overwhelming very
small gesture that wouldn't have worked
in a busy film you know it wouldn't have
resonated in the same way one of the one
of the things in John Dillman and
Chantal Ackerman's maybe her other films
too is the dialogue is not necessarily
advancing the story it's not there to be
the story the dialogue at least in John
Dillman is there to be just between the
characters it's something that concerns
them so she'll be talking about school
with her son at the dinner table but
it's not medicine really include the
audience in a kind of like story way
it's almost like music between the
mother and son as opposed to involving
the audience and we were doing that in
elephant and Todd kind of did that a bit
unsafe I think you know also the shots
are wider characters are smaller in the
frame a close-up is shocking you know
what
it happens and you feel distanced but
you're strangely compelled and safe was
I mean say it's so cozy like what we're
doing now yeah trying to get away from
yeah remember the moment there's a scene
where she's in the weird New Age camp
and she approaches someone in their hut
and they start screaming stay away stay
away that happened to be yesterday of
where I am a question for you John from
Danny will we ever see a hedwig sequel
I don't think so Stephen Trask was not
really interested the composer I did
start to write it with him as a theater
piece but he couldn't really express why
at first he didn't want to but to me I
don't ever feel a kind of sophomore
slump or whatever just maybe because
I've been acting for so long that a new
thing is just a new thing I don't feel
the pressure of the last thing having to
measure up or anything I really don't
and because I know that Kent things come
and go and people's interest comes and
goes and ahead big was a flop on the
screen and it barely hung on
off-broadway it was not ever really
accepted or a hit till years later I
mean the DVD made it a cult thing and
people passed it from you know manicured
you know nail polished hand to hand and
that that's was you know that's very
head big you know she didn't had wig
have all these performances in different
cities though all across the nation it
was like it was one in Portland LA San
Francisco I mean it was a play which is
also different from drag because other
people could play the role no one else
is gonna play Lady Bunny or
but this was a character you know that
anyone could play and that I come from
the theater and I was thrilled like a
parent when other people wanted to do it
interpret it the way they wanted to I
never wanted to control it so it it
metastasized but never made me money
because it wasn't a mainstream thing and
schools wouldn't do it because they were
scared at the draft that you know that
the operation was whatever it was it
scared them to me it feels very
traditional had Broadway you know to me
but I know why some people didn't think
it was now it's more part of the
Broadway his you know the Broadway when
we finally got to Broadway because they
weren't ready for us in the 90s we
brought it there 2014 with Neil Patrick
Harris America's Sweetheart and it was a
huge hit that was the very first time we
actually made money 25 years so that and
I you know I wasn't famous enough to
even open it you know I had I replaced
myself later which I was very happy to
do you know I didn't have to do all the
press and we will do it again you know
I'm still in theater returns so anthem
homunculus is what remained of the
Hedwig sequel that used to be in head
digs voice but we took the story which
is about a down-and-out person in a
trailer in Junction City Kansas who has
a brain tumor and his crowdfunding his
treatment we took Hedwig out of it like
a benign tumor and it became about me a
version of me so I don't really feel the
need to revisit the character though it
changes form you know doing the origin
of love tour which is really about the
making of hedvig is a kind of version of
I'm not playing the character but I'm
referring to it and dressed sort of as
her so I love that it changes shape the
other key people can play it you know
all genders have played it I'll generate
gender identifications it's a mask it is
drag you know it's not a trans story
because the character was forced into
this box bashed operation by what i
called the by narky of his boyfriend and
family and government saying you have to
be this if you want to be free you have
to this is what we've decided a woman is
and this is a man and he's mutilated you
know to fit into that patriarchal
version of gender
whereas we all have energies that are
called male and female and if we don't
express them terrible things happen you
know it's like a an animal dying in your
wall it can really stink the place up
and you know I'm very much a person
that's against the binary key because I
believe that's a version of control and
and and even capitalism you know if you
can define it you can sell to it and you
can control it real pretty much at a
time someone was asking about screening
platform as we mentioned I think it's
only criterion we talked about criterion
has I hope it's got head big it's great
they did a wonderful pack blu-ray for
Hedwig on criterion I think it's
probably also on HBO max because it's a
warner film our films tend to get lost
you know that's another strange thing
about the digital revolution is that the
small films aren't necessarily
moneymakers so they don't get grabbed by
the streamers and right now Shortbus is
not available anywhere except an old DVD
and i don't know if it's the same from
mala noche you have to get the blu-ray
you know on criterion and we're hoping
criterion does short bus to so if you
wanted to see that happen give them in
their print channel as well right you
can stream yeah yeah yeah we love
criterion I mean there
savior's I okay yeah any other pics you
talked about a lot of your favorites any
other like queer pics for people who
watch any favorites Gus one of the last
ones that I can't find at the moment is
a Derek Jarman film called
the last of England oh yes which is
really beautiful but it might be
somewhere I mean I think you can see see
a little bit of it on YouTube but for
somebody's that's a British Film
Institute film too so maybe in England
maybe there's a way to see it yeah I
think there is a BFI blu-ray but that's
when I actually met him I it premiered
at Berlin and 88 I think and so I got to
meet him and it was so you know he
really had a very saint-like demeanor
you know he was a true godfather and
very benevolent you know and but uh but
also an instigator and you know he was
he was you know Caravaggio and edward ii
meant a lot to me as a kid and last of
england was less effective for me but it
was very very interesting yes that's the
arty one it's very arty and then there's
blue yes which is even more arty because
the screen is nothing but a blue-black
it's like a podcast it's a podcast and
in fact I was inspired by blue to do a
anthem homunculus marathon I've done
I've done it in a few cities before Ovid
where we create we actually created
abstract visuals and we would play all
five and a half hours with breaks I even
handed out some THC drops and and and
blankets like it was a flight or
something
it's a psychedelic flight well this is
being a coffee tour with film
independent find out more about us at
film in a planet org or on the socials
at some independent dependent Instagram
and Facebook
but just leads me to say thank you to
our two guests today John Cameron
Mitchell John thank you so much thank
you it's good to see you again
is this gonna be anywhere archived
anywhere yeah they'll be on our YouTube
channel and probably look great and go
Spencer thank you thank you soon